tres exigencias se unieron desde
temprano a miles de mujeres en asia
áfrica y europa este 8 de marzo
reivindicación respeto e igualdad con
las ya tradicionales pancartas verdes
violetas cientos se concentraron en la
capital francesa para reclamar mejores
condiciones laborales y políticas
los trabajos de mujeres están mal
pagados y no se valoran la pandemia
arrojó luz sobre su importancia así que
realmente estamos aquí para gritar alto
y claro que estos trabajos deben ser
reevaluados y los salarios deben
aumentar
el eco de los reclamos en esta fecha
conmemorativa se extendió hasta las
calles de tokio
incluso con la misma formación académica
que los hombres todavía hay una brecha
entre mujeres y hombres como no poder ir
a la misma universidad o no conseguir
empleo
creo que hay muchas personas molestas
por esto pero espero que las mujeres del
futuro puedan estar orgullosos de ser
mujeres y que el mundo pueda convertirse
en uno solo sin desigualdad social
en delhi fueron más de 20.000 las que
rechazaron las imposiciones de un
sistema que califican como opresor y
patriarcal las mujeres representan la
mitad de la población de este país y
también tienen derecho a expresar sus
pensamientos esta etapa nos está dando
la libertad de plantear eso este es un
día importante porque representa la
fuerza de las mujeres si todas estamos
unidas entonces podemos lograr nuestro
objetivo mucho más rápido
temía mar las manifestantes colgaron sus
tradicionales faldas en improvisados
tendederos que levantaron en las calles
de yangon como mecanismo para frenar a
los policías que buscaban evitar la
movilización ya que en ese país caminar
por debajo de estas prendas es presagio
de mala suerte para los hombres mientras
que en estambul fueron decenas las que
protestaron contra el abuso en filipinas
más de 400 activistas exigieron un alto
a los feminicidios y denunciaron las
violaciones a sus derechos por parte de
la administración de rodrigo intertek
sin distinción de nacionalidad o lengua
a mí les reiteraron este lunes el poder
de su lucha una que sólo persigue la
igualdad